hello welcome to Stanford's webinar on
the new graduate joint degree program in
computer science of business my name is
Allison Davis and I'm with the MBA
admissions office I'm joined by my
colleague Becky Sharbot who is a career
advisor at the Business School Career
Center Mary
Aleksey who oversees the joint and dual
degree programs for the business school
and J Subramanian who is director of
admissions from computer science we have
45 minutes today and we do have lots of
information we'd like to share with you
thank you to so many of you who did send
in questions in advance your questions
fell into several specific topics which
we're going to address in the next 45
minutes so I'm going to start with
asking Mary who again oversees the joint
and dual degree programs for the
business school and if you do pursue
this joint you will get to do Mary very
well because she will be advising you on
on your your program while you're here
and Mary if you could start out by
telling us the purpose of the joint
degree and and the value of it yeah
absolutely so welcome everybody just a
few things about this joint degree
program I think many folks know that
Stanford is really well known as being
an incubator for new technology ventures
so we feel like this degree is going to
be really complementary to that endeavor
and our hope is that this degree is
going to foster innovation that Springs
naturally from two of our world-class
programs being the GSB and our computer
science department so the purpose of
this degree program is going to be to
provide an opportunity for computer
scientists to develop necessary skills
to be managers and entrepreneurs and for
technologically inclined business
students to gain a solid background in
computer science by combining these two
degrees into a really focus and
intentional approach
so what the program looks like it's a
three year program that you would
ideally start at the GSB and do one year
of our core curriculum coursework
following that you would have two years
of really a blend of MBA electives along
with computer science required courses
and computer science electives this is a
full-time program so we do not offer
part-time or remote learning
opportunities the idea is that you are
here with us for three years full time
in person and II will be the program
breaks out into 84 GSB or MBA units
along with 45 computer science units to
a total of a hundred and twenty-nine
units and again you would be completing
that in three years we don't have a set
number of students that will be in the
program as we are really looking for
quality or than quantity and so it's
really students that fit this either
business wanting to have the technology
lean or starting computer science and
wanting the business and leadership
skills I'm going to turn to Jay now from
computer science and Jake talk a little
bit about who is this program really
meant for who is the ideal candidate
hello everyone I'm super looking to lead
organizations for teams in a technical
environment anyone who is at the
intersection of Technology and business
it's a combination or being able to get
the technical skill set as a result of
doing the master's in computer science
program next Jay and I would like to
walk you through the application
requirements for each of the programs
and you do apply to the program
separately and you
a different application so let me start
with the MBA and here on my screen I'm
showing you the application deadlines
for students coming September of 2014
and for the MBA program you do have a
choice of three application deadlines
and you see the application deadlines
and then when you would receive your
decision so for the NBA if you were
interested in applying for computer
science as well we would strongly
discourage to apply in round one or
round two deadline and the reason for
that is so that you get your decision
for the MBA before it before you get
your decision from computer science so
you can be making an informed decision
about your options if you are you can
apply in round three that's that's
certainly possible but what will happen
is that you will get a decision from the
Business School in May and you will have
had to reply to your offer from computer
science in April so if you want to be
able to students to know your full
options you would apply and round winner
round round one around two so basically
for the Business School there's an
application form and you can access it
adhere on the apply but if you're
applying for this joint degree program
you must take the GRE you do not take
the GMAT if you're an international
student we would require you both
schools would require you to take the
TOEFL with a minimum score 113 so again
if you're applying only to the MBA you
have some other options for your English
language test but if you are applying
for the joint degree you must take the
TOEFL we ask you for academic transcript
of course and employment history there
is no work
experience that is required you can come
here straight from university at the
business school we do ask you for a set
of essays and the essay questions are
posted here on our website you can refer
to those we also ask for three letters
of reference and these should come two
of them from a professional relationship
so it could be a previous supervisor or
client vendor one of them should be from
a current supervisor and if you're
coming in without work experience it
could be from a summer job or it could
be from an interesting that and then the
third reference needs to be from a peer
and that could be a fear in a work
situation or in an extra to a shion's to
go back the recommendations for a moment
with a to professional one second one as
I mentioned to be from a previous
supervisor or it could be from an
extracurricular activity so you know if
you did some volunteer work for somebody
who supervise you in that capacity
so I'm going to now turn it over to Jay
and she can walk you through the
application process for suicide so to
start off there's only one admission
cycle for the master's in computer
science programs and that is in autumn
quarter all the students are that are
applying to our master's program are
being considered to come in for the
autumn quarter I know there were a lot
of questions in terms of can what what's
the kind of background that we're
looking for for the students who are
applying to them SCS program you do not
have to have a CS undergrad major but
we're looking at strong analytical and
quantitative skills so that is something
that you should bear in mind when you're
applying to this program apart from that
we're looking
the statement of purpose that the
students are required to submit and all
of this application process is done
online your statement of purpose should
be very concise focused and well written
and clearly indicate the reasons in
terms of why you applying to this
program there's three letters of
recommendation that is required and we
recommend that at least two of these
letters come from academic sources our
NSCs program is a poor space there's a
45 unit requirement therefore we want to
look at your academic potential or when
you are bringing in your letter of
recommendation so pretty letters of
recommendation statement of purpose
everyone is required to take the GRE
scores and for the international
students they are required to take TOEFL
scores other than that if you have any
work experience to do highlight that in
your statement of purpose but you're not
required to have a work experience in
order to apply for this program just you
know mention about your capacity for
analytical thinking and ability to
express your analytical and quantitative
skills when you are writing up your
statement of purpose that's kind of in a
nutshell in terms of what the
requirements and the background of the
students should be Jay what about the
recommended courses that they might take
if they have a non technical background
so for those who do not have a CS
background and it is recommended that
you take some of these foundation
courses here's our this list of the
foundation courses that could help you
in preparing better for applying to the
MSBs program for particularly for those
who do not have a CS background or
do not have a strong analytical and
quantitative skills are not coming from
more of the humanity humanities and
Sciences background this will kind of
better prepare you to apply for the
master's in computer science program and
if you want a more detailed information
about what the course syllabi for each
of these courses is if you're going to
span for that meeting our main website
and spectres are be armed yes please and
on the Explorer and if you click on the
on the search side right here explore
courses it brings up all the courses
that are available at our University and
then if you can if you type the CS 103
you can see a little description of what
what this published course is all about
and if there's any prerequisite involved
so that is how you can type in each of
these foundation courses and get more
information on what the course content
is like you to be so J does need to do
some of this preparation they could look
at the course descriptions and then look
for those courses in their local area
that correct cover set correct and they
don't necessarily need to be at the
graduate level that could be
undergraduate that expresses already
them at a community college perhaps or
absolutely expulsion can anywhere and as
part of their application then would
they would it be a good idea for them to
send the transcripts of these courses
yes alum transcripts indicating that
they have taken these courses and done
well would certainly give them a better
edge could they take these courses
through the Stanford continued
professional development why there's an
option of taking these courses far
credit through the non degree option
program and for that you will have to go
to the SCPD Stanford center for
professional development
SCPD edu and look at the courses that
are being offered through these nd
aprendido programs and apply to them and
get accepted and is there some advantage
would they have an edge because it's a
Stanford course and no that's not really
true because you know we're looking at
applications that's coming from all over
the world and several other aspects are
also taken into consideration when
they're being reviewed I know some
people have written an in advance asking
of work experience was required it is
not required for applying to the program
however if they don't have the work
experience I would encourage them to
mention it on their statement of purpose
then that's definitely a highlight
yesterday and work experience in in high
tech is that pervert or desire it's not
required so there's no preference at
section so if they have it by all means
highlight it but if you don't have it
it's not like you're not eligible to
apply to the program of getting on a
requirement degree Thank You J and now
I'm going to turn to Becky
Charlotte from our Career Management
Center and she's going to talk about
what would be some of the career paths
that students graduating from this joint
degree might pursue and what the general
career opportunities are for students
from this joint degree so Betty
great thanks Helen hi everyone I'd like
to add my welcome to the mix so thanks
for being on the call as Alice
introduced me earlier I work in the
Career Management Center I'm a
recruiting relationship manager so I
spend a lot of my time meeting with
companies particularly in technology and
then I meet with students on a case by
case basis as well doing more tactical
advising so not necessarily the big
picture career in life vision I'm going
to help you narrow down your focus but
more you know you want to work in tech
you know you want to work in whatever
particulars function and we can talk
about companies and we talk about
context and ways to communicate with
those companies so that's kind of my
background I do a lot of tech outreach
so in this past year I've communicated
with the way over 200
everything from e-commerce to consumer
internet enterprise big data from the
two persons startup - the googles and
the apples of the world so and
everything in between I think that every
single company I talked to basically
every company I talked to says do you
have engineers so if you obviously
you're interested in pursuing this
degree so you're you're you know very
interested in this space if our MBA
students a number of them do you come
from engineering backgrounds but a lot
of them now obviously are looking at
this as an opportunity to pursue a
career and really bring something extra
to the table a lot of students come to
me wanting to do product management and
I think that obviously if you're able to
talk the talk of an engineer and be able
to speak to both engineers and lead
cross-functional teams both from a
business side and an engineering side
you don't necessarily have to code as a
product manager however if you can that
is incredibly desirable and a lot of
companies are looking for that so I
would say more and more these days
companies are asking for come for our
students to be able to code maybe not
every single day but Julie's have that
that knowledge and that familiarity so
obviously they're not just product
management roles that you can pursue in
tech there's many many more but that is
the one that tends to come up most
specifically for companies that want
engineering backgrounds and I think in
this in this industry you know you're in
the Silicon Valley it is tremendous if
you're able to like I said bring that to
the table so I think this is a really
unique opportunity and that would allow
you to do that and do it very well
Becky a lot of our students just
generally in the MBA program are
interested in entrepreneurship and a
good percent iswhat was it so lack of
her bad way between 10 and 15 percent of
people of MBA students pursuing their
own company their own startups within
the last couple of years right and so
would you talk a little bit about how
the computer science that that
background might
helped them with their own ventures yeah
absolutely so a lot of our MBA students
as we were just saying do pursue their
own startup and we have a wonderful
venture lab through the Center for
entrepreneurial studies that allows
students to kind of have their own
incubator here at the GSB and work with
the Center for entrepreneurial studies
to get advising on best practices and
tips and tricks for starting you know
the very basics and workshops for
starting their own company a lot of
students will try to if they don't have
an engineering background they'll work
with students they'll try to work with
students in the School of Engineering
but what we're finding is that again
more and more venture capitalists want
students who have the knowledge and the
skill set from both sides so a lot of
engineers will start their own company
because they can they can create their
company so to speak and you know they
can kind of figure out the business side
but on the business side if you can't
create your company from a from a design
and coding perspective you really need
to partner with an engineer right so in
this case if you have the ability to do
both drive the business and create the
the foundation and the code and the
design for the company I mean you can do
it all basically so I think there is
definitely the opportunity for MBAs to
partner with people in CS but again I
think from a start-up perspective if you
have a knowledge to it leave at least a
familiarity to do both you're going to
be weights and balance above actually
among our current students we certainly
have had entrepreneurs that the reason
they're pursuing the MBA is they had
some kind of failed venture and it was
typically not a failure because of the
product idea but because they weren't
able to manage the organization you know
the HR function they weren't able to be
really savvy about the financing and so
often that is why they're coming for the
MBA
they've had a venture fail so you know
to really be successful with your own
venture you know being able to be
strategic and to really understand
organizational behavior which is what
you'll get from the MBA side is going to
be a huge asset I think that's a great
point I think there's definitely if you
can like out something if you can do
both you're going to be golden in the
valley so let's move actually
let's move on to talk about during the
program what are the opportunities and
I'm going to look to you Becky and Jay
what are the opportunities to interact
with Silicon Valley companies what are
the internship opportunities that a
joint degree students would have so we
have a computer forum in our department
that connects a lot of our students in
fact it's open to any student wants to
look at internship opportunities and
eventually job prospects with Silicon
Valley companies so these are all member
companies that have signed up under this
computer form so a lot of our students
are actually advice and guided in terms
how to write up your resume and how they
can do interviewing true for an
internship or a full time or a
contractual position so technically the
students are connected with a Silicon
Valley company where they come in and do
career affairs or job interviews in our
departments that we have a couple of
conference rooms under a lined up for
them and there's also a huge event that
happens once a year where we get all of
these member companies to come and talk
about what they're looking for and also
look at possibly look at some of our
students who are graduating to hire them
eventually so those are some of the
activities that our computer science
students can get involved with what kind
of what are some of the
deniz that are members of this computer
forum oh so you know certain companies
that come to my mind are Google
Microsoft Yahoo Facebook I mean these
are companies that are in the Silicon
Valley so it's all footballs are green
yes there are some that are outside of
the Bay Area and I'll come in for this
with your form I found me next one yeah
I think that's a question that people
will have is is their job prospects
really limited to the Silicon Valley
what do you think sexy so I think the
answer sure answer is no the job
prospects are pretty much endless we do
have a large majority of students that
do stay in the Silicon Valley I think
that's largely won by choice because yet
you really can't beat the weather and
and the things to do obviously but to
because this is the heart of a lot of
where technology is now of course New
York Silicon Alley of course that's
tremendously growing and there's a large
interest there we do a lot of outreach
there as well one of the things that I
wanted to talk about was the the
outreach trips that both the Career
Management Center as well as student
clubs do so for example this year the
student the high tech Club led a trek to
South by Southwest
I felt fortunate that I got to tag along
with them but basically they met with
HomeAway
Facebook Austin ventures there was a
alumni reception hosted at home away and
then we met with about 50 companies
throughout the South by Southwest
weekend so a really great opportunity to
network with companies all over the
country and all over the world really
that come and kind of gravitate toward
that type of event but there's a number
of other events that the Career
Management Center as well as both the
high tech Club and the Entrepreneurship
Club and the venture capital Club drive
for Stanford students and I think it's
really a Stanford offers a lot of really
unique networking based opportunities
and educational opportunities for
students and so obviously I can speak to
the NBA sidesteps student population
that I work with a couple of those
examples are we hosted a tech crawl last
October it was basically envision a pub
crawl to filmer company so companies in
the South of Market area in San
Francisco so we visited some early-stage
startups or mid mid stage startups like
jawbone
TaskRabbit inkling Hipmunk
so a number of different companies that
we visited for that in each company
hosted us with you know cocktails or
beverages and snacks so that was a
really fun way to interact with
companies we've got we work very closely
with a lot of venture firms so we hosted
a speed networking event with a venture
firm last February February where they
brought in ten of their portfolio
companies and each company gave a
two-minute spiel about what they were
looking to do for hiring what their
company was all about and then really
gave a really personalized opportunity
for students to network with them and
then we also hosted a fewer than 300
event in April which brought in about 30
early-stage startups all with fewer than
300 employees and it's like a really fun
kind of casual networking opportunity
that students were able to source jobs
and internships from and then finally we
do the crew management center sponsors
company networking nights so we do those
we did two of those in the fall and we
bring in over 40 companies both large
and small this is more of a traditional
event so some of the companies like Jay
was speaking about like the Microsoft
and the apples of the world will come to
those types of events for networking
opportunities that then leads into
on-campus recruiting and that's all
hosted by the Career Management Center
and about 70% of our MBA students do
participate in on campus recruiting so
obviously that would be very much
available to you and this program as
well it is typical to at both the
computer science department and the
business school for students to do
summer internships and so could you talk
a little bit about summer internships
Jay that computer science and Becky is
from a business school perspective so a
lot of students either apply directly to
the companies and because they have the
advantage of doing the masters in
computer science from Stanford
University they get I would say more
preference as far as the internship
because of the fact that we're in
Silicon Valley we have a lot of our
current students who are doing summer
internship always Facebook and Yahoo and
Microsoft and we also facilitate by
through the computer form for them to
look at internship opportunities
typically these are done during summer
quarter for the master's in computer
science program thank you yeah so our
students pretty much 100 percent of our
students that want to pursue an
internship over their summer do get an
internship in this case I would imagine
there would be two internship
opportunities and so I think this
obviously a great way to expand your
skillset network within the tech
community you know in San Francisco or
the Bay Area or all over the world and
we do the chrome admin Center does a ton
to work with students on a very in
July's individualized basis to help them
pursue their interests the companies of
interest and make contacts both with
alumni as well as non alumni too so
there's a very you know we work very
closely with students from that
perspective and so internships are
definitely something that most if not
all students pursue right and one thing
I'd like to emphasize is if you're part
of this joint degree program you are
welcome and to take advantage of
opportunities at either school so you
may find that there are certain quarters
where you're only taking business school
courses or they're certain quarters
where maybe you're only taking computer
science courses or combination of both
but you are enrolled students at those
departments so you take advantage of all
the opportunities and resources at both
schools and that's true of all the clubs
your your can be a member of clubs at
those schools and and Mary I'd ask you
to comment a little bit from your
experience with other joint degree
programs just in terms of you know the
social life for joint degree students
are they kind of you know they're a
cohort or they part of the larger
community how does that work yeah thank
you and so I think all of our students
enjoy a very diverse upper side of
opportunities in regards to social life
there's just
a lot to do here and whether you start
here first at the GSB or if you choose
to start at your other program you are
always welcome and included in all of
the GSB student activities and events
from the joint and dual degree program
standpoint we do offer opportunities to
meet other joint students at the start
of the academic year so you'll have an
opportunity to kind of meet and greet
folks that are maybe starting at the GSB
first or folks that could be starting
with computer science first and it's a
really rich and active life here so I do
recommend it and I just want to add in
one little comment about housing because
there was a question about like well
where do I live do I live with MBAs or
do I live with computer science students
and really the question more has to do
with how Stanford runs its housing and
as a first year master's degree student
you have preference for on-campus
housing so most students in the first
year of their MBA or master's degree
will live on campus but in following
years they do tend to live off campus as
they've made friends and prefer that
off-campus living experience so again
you'll have the opportunity to take
advantage of the social opportunities
both from the computer science side and
the NBA side great one thing I'd like to
just loop back in terms of the
admissions process that I think we've
neglected to emphasize is that you do
apply to the two schools separately and
the decisions are made separately there
will be a place on the computer science
application where you're asked to check
a box if you're going to be applying to
the MBA program and the MBA application
there's a box for you to indicate that
you'll be applying to the computer
science but the decisions are made
separately and their note is known
maybe hopefully you'll be admitted to
both programs but you might be admitted
to one and not the other and you
certainly would have the option to
reapply but it's not like you're
disadvantaged in some way or there is
some advantage to apply to both programs
or one program it really is to separate
two separate processes so we're going to
wrap up here with talking about the cost
of the program and financial aid and the
tuition for the business school that I'm
this is on our website under financial
aid this is the tuition for students
coming in this fall so may of course be
different for next year but you can see
the student budget basically for a
single student living on campus tuition
and all the living expenses the cost of
the program is about 94 thousand per
year and then J for the computer science
portion those in terms of the tuition
cost we're talking about generally all
of the students take only three quarters
C quarters is generally considered to be
one academic year not everyone is
required to be enrolled in it summer
quarter each quarter costs about nine
thousand three hundred fifty which
totals up to 29 that's approximately 29
grand and that's the tuition cost under
the non-tuition child student housing
and all the other stuff amounts to about
27 141 so the total cost comes out to
Vic if I can round it off to about fifty
six thousand six hundred ninety one for
one academic year I'd like to bring in
Jack Edwards into the conversation here
because he is the financial aid director
at the business school and we would
encourage you if you're applying if
you're not a for example a current
computer science student at Stanford but
you are applying from the outside we
would recommend that if you are admitted
to
both programs that you would actually
start at the business school and because
there are some advantages in terms of
the financial aid and your financial aid
if you were to start the business school
would be administered for all three
years of your program by our GFC
financial aid office so I'm going to
turn it over to you jack and and have
you weigh in here so please folks and
welcome so as Alison mentioned the
advantage of starting at the business
school allows us to be able to provide
financial aid to you for the entire time
in your in the program what it also is
is that the business goals in a position
to be able to provide financing for all
students both domestic and international
students we have a our own international
student loan program that does not
require students to have a u.s. citizen
as a cosigner or require them to have
the u.s. Social Security number in order
to receive student loans financial aid
works in in that it will if you are
eligible we will consider ul4 Fellowship
dollars for six total cement quarters
and then in the third year if you're
doing your studies you would be eligible
to borrow student loans in order to fund
for those costs
our hope is since this programs new is
is that eventually down the road that we
may be able to find resources for
fellowship dollars for specifically for
a master's in computer science MB a
joint degree student these are things
for us on the horizon that we will be
working towards and so eventually we may
have funding that may be eligible
through fellowship dollars free money to
be eligible in your third year I know
some of you have submitted questions
asking
about the Reliant fellowship and if you
were could you apply to the Reliant
fellowship and be part of this program
and the answer is yes that you could yes
you could but the reliance program is
strictly for the two years right in that
bit so it would only cover the two years
that you're being billed your MBA cloth
MBA tuition okay so Jack can you walk
through a little bit then so somebody's
here for eight or nine quarters you know
are they paying they're they're paying
GSB tuition for six of those quarters
and whatever the other two quarters are
would be at the Graduate Stanford
graduates yeah that's correct
so the six quarters that you are as
classified as the MBA student your
tuition billing will be based as the
Business School caught tuition costs and
in your third year you would be billed
as a graduate engineering tuition rates
which sometimes is a little bit
different than just some other graduate
programs at the University so and so
there's a cost savings because of the
difference in the cost between the
business school and the engineering
schools right and if we didn't mention
it earlier you the the advantage of I
mean there are many advantages to doing
the joint program but one advantage is
if you were to do these two degrees
separately you would probably be here an
extra one or two quarters so you are
saving up to one or two quarters of
tuition by doing the joint program we do
need to close in a few minutes I think
I'll just ask Mary if you have any
advice since you do everyday advise
joint degrees students in the program if
you have any advice about being a joint
degree student here or the application
process anything you'd like to add yeah
I would just encourage all of you out
there to really think about what is your
goal or what is your focus what are you
trying to accomplish and what is the
right pathway because for some folks it
might be that just taking a handful of
CS courses is going to be okay or for
some folks that could be just taking a
handful
business courses is going to be okay but
if you have a really clear vision for
yourself whether it's that you want to
start your own company or you're looking
to kind of lock in with a kind of
pre-existing what I'll call one of those
mega companies from Silicon Valley then
this degree could be a really good fit
for you I think there are lots of
powerful ways you either leverage your
degree based on who you are and what
your network is or by leveraging the
resources offered by both computer
science and the GSB and we're really
excited about this degree and we're
excited to support the students and just
a reminder as Mary says you can as a
business school student take courses at
in the computer science department and
up to 12 of those units can actually
count towards your MBA degree so just a
reminder about that and then Jay any
last words you'd like to add in terms of
computer science um I think um there was
a question about coursework loan
typically if you err as the School of
Engineering you require to take 8 to 10
units each unit is about each class is
about 3 units and we're talking about 15
hours a week of work so 8 to 10 units
would be about 24 hours a weekend and it
really depends on the combination of
courses that you're taking any course
some students are super ambitious and
take more of that but and there will be
a different tuition if you went above
the 10 unit limit I just wanted to make
that point and I would encourage
everyone to take a look at the course
requirement for the MS es program on our
computer science website and there's a
kind of a skeleton outline of the
courses that you can take if you choose
a specialization in the MSC s program if
you have further questions you can
either contact the MBA admissions office
and here is our contact information
you can ask a question via email or
telephone s were open 8:00 to 4:00
Pacific time and that's irony I'll email
and telephone number students a welcome
to the email that set that wonderful
well thank you so much Becky Mary Jack
and J for participating this morning and
thank you all out in the audience for
your attention in your interest we're
glad that you're interested in Stanford
and hope to see some of you here on
campus in the next few years